grab your cowboy hats the tough
heaterman bull riding championship is
coming to town and jj harrison bull
riding entertainer and barrelman is here
to tell us all about it first and
foremost when i got out here he's like
do you what do you know about bull
riding and i said a check you gotta know
that happens
you don't want to fall off and that's
very true you're you're an expert in
bull riding i am an expert okay so first
and foremost again what is a barrelman
and what is your job my job is a lot of
entertainment we try to protect the
cowboys if we uh have a bull rider you
know when they come out the bulls are
going to spin the bulls going to get
dizzy the cattle's going to get dizzy
when they get thrown off the bull
fighters and the barrel men will do our
best to make sure the bull rider can get
back to the fence and live to tell the
story and brag to his girlfriend right
that's what you do now you do this in
full costume correct normally yeah
normally i'll be in makeup i thought it
might scare you so i left the makeup off
makeup we uh we we dress up and and
you'll have a good time when you come
out but uh we're set up for it man did
we just i think we might have just
showed you on the screen somewhere those
are fans those are fans that's the arena
right there beautiful south point tough
edema when he's he's a four-time world
champion bull rider right right and when
he retired from bull riding he wanted to
give back to the sport there he is right
there he wanted to uh keep fans
entertaining keep people hooked to bull
riding and i tell you what his there's
me he said
he has been more for the bull rider
than a lot of guys ever will and it's
really great the south point's a perfect
home for us and we put on a fast-paced
quick action bull riding there's no dead
spots there's no downtime in it if you
like rodeo if you like bull riding this
is the place to be now what is everybody
competing for what what's what's that
yeah
so the way tough
rigs up the bull riding is if the event
before
a guy doesn't ride all the way to the
end if we don't have a champion of it
that money gets to roll over that means
the south point tough heaterman tour is
offering 50 000
up for grabs in in this this saturday
night bull riding the cool thing though
too and i like to talk about this he
does a lot for the bull riders but the
guys that bring bulls the stock
contractors are also where you get the
bulls from yeah they're also in a
competition so those guys are bringing
bulls and if they have the bull that
goes all the way and runs wins the
championship the rider rides their bull
they have a chance at 50 000 on their
own as well as well oh there's a lot
this is a big deal hundred thousand
dollars up for grabs at the south point
and and i tell you what microgun south
point is one of the greatest things for
cowboys not for not just the nfr in
december but i tell you there's a great
horse show there too absolutely raining
there's always that arena is beautiful
it's set up good we pack it though so
get tickets early uh well how can people
do that they go to south point yeah go
online okay tough you to mature uh
google it you'll find it man there's
lots of ways easy right now you've been
doing this for what five years
here in vegas i've done well i've worked
the national finals rodeo down to thomas
and mack i've done tufts uh las vegas
event for i think this is my fourth year
fourth year in a row and i tell you i
love vegas yeah i love las vegas i
really do i love the people that live
here i love the tourists that come here
this is a town of entertainment and when
you're in entertainment business there's
only one place to be and that's good
absolutely we got something for
everybody here and how does one
get your job though i feel like this is
a unique are you gunning for me are you
gunning for me right now is that just
our weekend gig and
clown makeup and cowboy hat sounds fun
all right first of all you can't be
afraid to get run over by a two thousand
pound bull they're gonna get my hands
dirty it's fine i got this a lot of it
you know the funny thing about me
personally is i was a school teacher i
taught school for eight years i got a
master's degree in education and i uh
and i now i wear makeup and work nights
you know so really what i found was that
you got to find something that you're
passionate about that you love and then
you find a career based around that so
my job is is really just entertainment
with a very dangerous stage yeah like
that like that perfect for vegas perfect
for vegas so you guys got to come on
down saturday for the championship yep
at the south point 50 000 bucks up for
the grabs for the bull riders and the
stock contractors at the south point and
a lot of fun you bet you're entered you
want to come yeah as long as i'm riding
sunday is around the